my name is Ayana Presley
I represent the Massachusetts 7th
congressional district
before coming here I asked my
constituents what message they wanted me
to deliver to the children and families
here today they asked me to deliver a
message that you are welcome here and
that we will look that we love you and
that we will never stop fighting for
your dignity for your humanity and for
the preservation of your family today I
was able to deliver that message and
we've talked about the most vulnerable
amongst us our children but I want to
talk about their parents the mothers the
awareness
let's see yes the montrezl that i sat
with not even knowing our names because
of the trauma they are experiencing and
because they don't know where that
children are keep yelling this is very
appropriate behavior
words and policies here on the floor the
house of representatives this is about
the preservation of our humanity and
this is about seeing family and the
safety the humanity and the freedoms
children being negotiated and
compromised and moderated
we made a system networks these humane
if it is compassionate and that keeps
families together I learned a long time
ago that would change happens
it's hardly because people see the light
or they feel the fire since I we're
lifting up these stories in the hopes
that you will see the lights and if you
don't we will bring the fire
[Music]